don't know how i missed this one uh i
saw a comment coming about this first
look at
j jonah jameson and marvel's spider-man
miles morales
if i'm not mistaken in the spider-man
ps4 game i don't think you ever see jay
jonah jameson you hear a lot
of like the audio from him a lot of
times we were swinging around his
reports and such i don't think you
actually maybe you see him on a
billboard or you see some of his body
but
i don't think there's an actual scene
with him there at least in the main
storyline
hey let's see what they got
hello spidey fans alex from game
informer here the hilarious ranting by j
jones
damn damn
damn just to write this anger
insomniac says he writes him better than
too anyone he's a low energy menace
maybe he's a weep minded
paige
you still don't see him
voice actor naji jeter worked with
numerous coaches to get the true new
eureka spanish dialogue down
which is specific to puerto ricans born
and raised in
so much more details
nice thanks if you enjoyed this look be
sure to go over to youtube.comer for
more exclusive looks at marvel's
oh dude no game informer you were
delivering
and it's cool getting those fun facts
about uh who writes for jay jonah
jameson and i love how
even in here he's kind of like the
wilson from home improvement who use
face you don't see that
oh man we're so close to seeing jay
jones's face but we don't see it
it still captures the voice perfectly of
him even throughout the spider-man ps4
game but this sequence is great you look
good jonah that was so
funny it's santa claus costume i mean we
do at least see him on the show
advertising and whatnot but yeah not in
motion and it's funny
like to me i don't know who the voice
actor is here but i was getting flashes
of both brian cranston and phil hendry
which is funny because you know jk
simmons you have such a strong
association with but i also
i love that little tidbit about the uh
new eurekan accent yeah they
worked with uh their main actor for too
well they seem to
actually show a lot here like i haven't
seen any of this footage that they've
had of both of them working together to
have to chase
rhino through the streets of new york
like going through the shopping mall
center looked incredible i love when
they swing through that one building and
it goes
it's like straight out of a movie and
then the chase keeps on
going i don't think we had a level like
that in the previous spider-man game for
sure not where we got two spider-man
what about one with christmas i mean you
had to go up against rhino but i don't
recall one word chased him through the
streets of
new york uh that looked great and i love
like him having to talk with his mom is
essentially kind of like when peter has
to talk to aunt may in the first game
that's when he's talking with his mom
and then
going in and out of english and spanish
there's a lot of cool nuances here man
i got a lot from this little clip feels
like a living comic book i can't wait to
see jay jonas
jamison's face actually brought in here
with some real cinematics baby can't
wait let's
do it all right guys what do you think
about this clip i
forgot who left the comment here but
thank you for letting me know subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit the like button
enjoy the rest of your day and evening
people cheers
[Music]
you